أنا لا أقفز
بعدك ، هذا ما قاله ضابط شرطة تيمبي أريزونا
لرجل كان يغرق في خزان
يوم 28 مايو ،
ما يحدث في
لقطات كاميرا الجسم هذه التي أصدرتها
مدينة تيمبي تُظهر ما يقرب من 12 دقيقة من
التفاعل بين ثلاثة ضباط
تم استدعاء شون بيكنغز البالغ من العمر 34 عامًا وضباطه في
البداية بعد الساعة الخامسة صباحًا في ذلك اليوم بشأن
شجار مزعوم ، هل لم تتعرضوا
لأي مواجهة
جسدية ونفى شريكه أي
عنف جسدي تقول مدينة تيمبي إنهم
لم يكونوا كذلك  تم احتجازه ولكن وفقًا
للسياسة ، قام الضباط بعد ذلك بإجراء
عمليات التحقق من الخلفية حيث
تم التحقق من أسمائهم بحثًا عن
مذكرات توقيف معلقة ، وتسلق المتسابقون فوق
درابزين وسألوا عما إذا كان حرًا في الذهاب ما
تفعله ،
فلا يمكنك إيقاف رجل البحيرة.
لا يُسمح له بالسباحة في البحيرة ، شاهد
تشارلز رامسي قائد شرطة العاصمة السابق
، مقطع الفيديو والتسجيلات التي ربما
تكون قد أتيحت له الحرية في المغادرة ولكن ليس حراً في
السباحة
في الخزان.
هناك شيئان مختلفان
الآن سواء
أتيحت الفرصة للضباط مرة
أخرى لإيقافه أم لا ، لا أعرف حقًا إلى أي مدى
تعتقد أنه سيكون قادرًا على
السباحة متأكدًا تمامًا من وجود مثل التوربينات
في قاعدة السد  يمكن أن تمتص ،
لا يمكننا رؤية ما سيحدث بعد ذلك
لأن مدينة تيمبي لم
تصدر الفيديو بعد مشيرة إلى طبيعتها الحساسة
بدلاً من ذلك أصدرت المدينة هذا
النص ، فما هي خطتك الآن
يقول أحد الضباط إن بيكنجز
تستجيب سأغرق أنا '  أنا ذاهب إلى الغرق ،
يقول الضابط لا ، فأنت لست كذلك ، ثم
يقول ضابط آخر للمصابين بالذهاب إلى برج قريب من
الصرح يقول إنني أغرق ولا يمكنني ذلك ،
حيث يقول الضابط حسنًا ،
لن أقفز بعد ذلك.
يستمر في إظهار كيف أن شريك bigging
المسمى هنا كشاهد يتوسل بأنه
يغرق إنه يغرق إذا لم تأت
إلى هنا الآن يقول الضابط
إذا لم تهدأ سأضعك في
سيارتي وبعد ذلك تقول إنني  فقط
مذهول لأنه يغرق
أمامك مباشرة ولن تساعد في
إنقاذ المياه أمر خطير للغاية إذا لم تكن
مدربًا بشكل صحيح ، يمكنك إغراق نفسك في
محاولة إنقاذ شخص ما ولكن
في نفس الوقت إذا كنت قادرًا على
محاولة إنقاذ شخص ما ، فمن الواضح
هذا ما قد ترغب في القيام
به ، قالت جمعية ضباط التمبي إن الضباط
لا يتلقون تدريباً على الإنقاذ من المياه
وليس لديهم معدات لمساعدة
ناتاشا تشين سي إن لوس أنجلوس